scientists amateur astronomers and
people who have never seen a total
eclipse are getting ready for a
once-in-a-lifetime sky show parts of the
nation will fall into a shadow for a few
minutes on Monday it will be visible
across much of the continental US
Adriana Diaz is in Carbondale Illinois
and what's said to be the center of the
totality zone they dream a good morning
good morning come Monday everyone of
these seats will be filled with
stargazers we've met some people who've
been waiting for decades for Monday's
event and one amateur astronomer has
logged some serious miles in the name of
the Eclipse the first across the u.s. in
99 years the road to the Eclipse has
been long exhaustingly long for Geary
Parkerson when you first realized that a
total solar eclipse would cross the
country what was the reaction i first
realized it in 1967 and my reaction was
i needed to live long enough to see this
thing
63 seemed impossibly old in 1967 and it
doesn't fill it all all now for the last
15 months Gary the editor of an amateur
astronomy magazine has peddled an
average of 50 miles a day to promote
Monday's science spectacular to kids
across America what is this here this is
a telescope he brings the skies down to
their level through this telescope he
rigged to his bike something between 30
and 40,000 people have gotten to see
celestial objects through the telescope
maybe a future astronauts absolutely
certainly a few future astronomers and
yeah hopefully an astronaut or two he
set out from his hometown in Louisiana
in May 2016 with the goal of pedaling
all 48 contiguous states preaching the
galactic gospel ahead of Monday's
eclipse his only companion is his 150
pound bike the telescope gear all goes
over here and I live out of the bag on
the other side
you live out of this little bag yeah so
I've got I've got four shirts I've got
two shorts and three pair of underwear
and some socks so you need that's all I
need when you're on the road alone does
the sky you know particularly at night
so I've been in some very dark corners
of the United States since I left and
and but all through the country yeah it
guides me I know the stars I'm familiar
with them then so that gives me a sense
of direction that direction brought him
here through Carbondale Illinois where
we met him
this small college town has attained
celebrity status in the science world
because the eclipse will linger longest
in this area for all of two minutes and
41 seconds those bragging rights brought
in NASA which has touched down in
Carbondale they won't be alone 14,000
people will pack this sold-out Stadium
at Carbondale Southern Illinois
University Monday Mike country Anaka
says the atmosphere will be out of this
world the sight is something that's
gonna really please Americans and make
them think differently actually change
their viewpoint about a living here on
earth the first reactions however will
be in Oregon the first state to glimpse
the Eclipse Randall Milstein who teaches
astronomy at Oregon State University
can't wait people burst into tears cry
other people dance just stand with their
jaw open or literally fall backwards
onto the ground it's a stunning moment
in their life and one that they're not
likely to ever forget an unprecedented
few minutes that Gary Parkerson hopes
will inspire long-lasting change the
universe is the only thing I can think
of that's truly universal it unites us
in a way that of nothing else it's
something bigger than we are and it's
free for all of us all we got to do is
look up do you think the time is right
to be united yeah so I think we need all
the good news we can get
to make sure people experience this
unifying moment safely Gary's been
handing out Eclipse glasses like these
now he's given away already 7,000 of
them it's important to have them on as
the moon crosses over the Sun forming a
crescent but for those of us in the path
of totality once the moon fully covers
the Sun you can take them off and take
it all in Dana
Adriana Diaz thank you